death spiral that's how the Governor of
Puerto Rico describes the direction his
economy could be heading alejandro
garcia padilla said his Commonwealth's
debt must be restructured at the same
time Fitch cut its rating to CC Porto
Rico has been troubled for decades so
why is the island and it's three and a
half million people now facing a Greek
like default michelle kaske from
bloomberg news is with us Michelle when
will Puerto Rico default well that
remains to be seen but it looks like
it's getting closer and closer they did
yesterday the legislature approved a
budget that does allocate 1.5 billing
billion towards repaying its direct at
general general obligations and directed
of the government but their main utility
the their main electricity provider has
a July first deadline I'm lost at the
Commonwealth of Massachusetts there's
the Commonwealth of Puerto Rico but
Puerto Rico has a different rule book is
it fair to the American taxpayers is it
fair to the American tax that there are
Commonwealth and they're gonna be
treated differently than a state or
Detroit for the can't they can't go
bankrupt right so right they don't have
the legal ability to their entities
don't have the illegal ability to file
for chapter 9 in the same so what would
happen i'm curious what happens to them
if they continue this spiral well what
happens is that eventually if if they do
an actual payment default then you'll
have a rush of different creditors
heading to different courts suing the
Commonwealth so there there's a debate
in Washington about whether or not they
should be able to file for bankruptcy
right what's what's the argument for
them being able to file for bankruptcy
and what kind of people are making this
argument their congressional
representative he has crafted this bill
to allow puerto rican entities to file
for chapter 9 and what some people
believe that would do is it would offer
a legal framework a blueprint and that
would make this an easier process to get
through this debt restructuring can we
just put it off can we put it off for
we've been doing every three that's what
they've been doing villain barter jump
in here please i mean the Puerto Rico is
the unfortunate situation that it can't
the file for chapter 9 for basically
protection shell from creditors and it
also cannot call
MF to come in and provided this fun so
then the worst of all possible worlds oh
there are the worst of all possible
worlds but he'll bring up the chart here
Lori on if you would I mean I don't I
don't know me Madeline guards not gonna
come to the rescue here they're on the
edge of Athens down they go this is just
one of their bonds from 100 down to 40
they can't call a Madame Lagarde they
can't call them President Obama who do
they call on well they call on their
citizens their citizens are going to
have to endure less public services
they're going to have to pay more in
taxes and fees and they're gonna have to
learn to live with a small don't they
have a limitation of a minimum wage
structure and other boating issues and
Jones Act issues where their their their
hands are behind their back tied because
of Washington Washington won't bail them
out what is the outcome now that we're
finally at this point the outcome is
that they're going to have to in there
they're going to have to start some
austerity measures cut spending even
more and maybe something can come out of
Washington in terms of you mentioned the
Jones Act maybe that can be changed
maybe they can be exempt from federal
minimum wage with restriction so if they
can't if they can't file for bankruptcy
they have to restructure like a
sovereign would right so this is gonna
go through some negotiations it could be
a little bit painful what kind of
recovery are people expecting on these
securities so a bond goes from 100 to 30
what do I get well that's that's the
ultimate grad that's the big question is
which Puerto Rico credits will actually
go through restructuring and what would
you recovery recovery rate be for prepa
their main utility provider which is the
closest entity reaching a possible
default Moody's has suggested a recovery
rate about 65 to eighty percent of bed
if it's eighty percent that's not that
that can say mom sounds phenomenal yeah
zero containing what the film boaters
this part of the new mediocre Lagarde's
made a lot of person
okers you know whether it's the
Philippines or it's argentina's coach
you mentioned earlier Nelson one is this
the new mediocre this is a very old
problem and it is I think part of the
old mediocre the new video curve X a
whole bunch of countries that were
previously viewed as or no sub
continuities the previously viewed as a
sound and so it is a global issue now no
longer an issue specific poor countries
real quick michelle about half of mutual
funds are still at least partially
invested in puerto rico with these
downgrades today will some of them have
to get out now living mandated to get
out no because puerto rico has been a
speculative grade junk grade for well
over a year so a lot of these funds that
were restricted have either reduced
their holdings or have gotten out
already okay michelle kaske thank you so
much with bloomberg news on a story that
would be front and center professor
powder thank you so much for coming